[Music]
i i really honestly i i do do wish you
well in all your content and i will try
to pay attention with the time that i
have to go watch
um i i really enjoyed the cameo video
even though you didn't think it did well
i enjoyed it i was like this is this is
[ __ ] this is brilliant so um
appreciate it yeah so did they actually
approach you or did you like uh in real
life did they approach you or did you
they did a few times and the first few
times they reached out i just like
didn't even respond i just was like no
and then they kept doing it and so i
just agreed to like talk to one of the
the peop this rep that was reaching out
i just agreed to talk to her on the
phone and i told her on the phone i was
like i was like i i don't think that
people want to right want to hire me to
do a cameo and she was like well why
what's the harm in trying and i just was
like
i was like i guess it's like i think i'm
just kind of embarrassed like it just
seems like
a big enough deal that people are like
oh my god like i have to get a video of
you saying hi to my friend
um and so i was like sure and i made it
and then she was like okay now you have
to tell people about it on the internet
i was like oh my god i don't want to
tell them
i don't want them to know that they can
do this thing but like i made that video
this weekend and i've done 15 cameos
this week heavy really that's awesome
sorry so so is it i mean is it you do
you think it's profitable like not just
you know like um
like i i cause because obviously they're
requesting content it's not like content
that you want right they're requesting
it so yeah they're requesting stuff i
mean i i have to
within reason like let people know like
if they're like hey will you write a
song for my friend i'm like oh that's
like a lot more expensive than me just
like saying hi yeah right because like
but like someone the other day for their
birthday was like will you write me a
rap and i was like
sure and i did it and i was like and i
just read it off my computer and i was
like hey this isn't like a music video
right yeah i'm just writing around i
wrote you a wrap and i was like and that
you know but i was like
i i think it
could be profitable like the idea with
cameo for people who are at my tier is
like
volume and quantity because the videos
are 25 to order each so like it's not
like like i would i need to make a lot
of them if it's going to be something
that i'm going to make money on whereas
like the big celebrities that are on
there
it's like five hundred dollars to hire
them to say hi
hey happy birthday thanks right and so
if they do you know ten of those in a
week that's five grand like that's a
decent little chunk of change granite
it's all relative
to like what what you're right you're
used to making and stuff and what you
should have done is just set the price
at like five thousand dollars and see if
anyone would like
custom custom tick song five thousand
dollars and just see if anyone would
take you i'd just be like just like hey
if i can get like one
yeah
it's one yeah well get like three people
a year that buy a custom
your pal austin tick tock song
and that would be probably worth it
right that's my philosophy that's my
philosophy behind my rate when i work
with brands is i'm just sort of like my
rates like
kind of high i don't think it's high but
a lot of brands are like oh whoa that's
too high and i'm like it's really not
you're asking me to like write direct
produced act and star in a right
commercial for you and i'm i'm like my
rate is twenty five hundred dollars to
do that and i'm like i'm like you want
me to do all that for twenty five
hundred dollars and if you were to like
pay a production company to make you
that commercial it was much more 50
grand right right like it's really
enough but also if i make this video for
2 500 and do you advertise it and you
make this much of an income you're
making hand over fists on what you paid
to what you made so yeah
and and you're making this for this
it's like what what's happening right
now is the creator economy probably will
have to become unionized or something
just so that because what's happening is
you've got a bunch of like teenagers and
kids who brands are reaching out and
saying like hey if we give you a free
tv
yeah and 200 will you will you shout us
out that they're like hell yeah i will
like so so that they they can get a lot
of stuff for very when i first started
making branded content i didn't know
what to charge people and i started out
like
the first time someone asked i was like
250 and they were like yeah sure great
and i was like that's probably too low
and so the next time someone asked me i
was like how's 400 and they were like oh
it's great no problem and i was like
okay i need i need them to not be so
enthusiastic so i like bumped it up to
like 800 and they were still like
totally cool awesome so i was like how's
1500 and then they were like
you know i think we can make that work
and then i was like i landed at 2500
just because i was like
my philosophy now is like if people say
no that's okay because if i make 10
videos at 250
that's the same as one out of 10 people
saying yes to the 2500 right exactly
it's less work for the same amount of
money right i might as well you know
well and the worst the worse it can
happen is like my rate is 25 and they're
like eh that's a little high and if
you're like why like the project i know
i can produce it then you can say look
i'll do you a favor i really like your
brand let's do it at 2200 they're like
okay and then you're still you're still
in that universe of oh i don't know i'll
always tell people like what what can
you do i'll be right what works for you
and they'll be like
our whole budget for this whole project
is is like three thousand dollars so
that would be almost our whole budget
it'll be like okay how's 1500 and then
okay you know like something like that
right and like i'm willing to work with
people it's just i want a place to like
start out and be like this is what it is
but then i mean that just happened a guy
reached out and was like hey do you want
you wanted me to make a spec video for
this project that he's pitching to tick
tock and he wanted it done by this
tuesday and he
got in touch with me about it yesterday
and i was like since it's such a tight
turnaround and it's just he just wants
me to write the song but i was like 1500
for the song because it's really tight
it's a really tight window and he went
to tic toc and he was like the best they
can do is 800 and he's like so i just
told him don't worry about it and he's
like i told you don't worry and i was
like no dude i'll do it for 800. it's
fine i was like i need i need a gig
right now like but i just want
you know like i'm i'm happy to negotiate
there's no one saying that it's illegal
for me to accept right right a lower
rate well yeah you could take fifteen
thousand dollars if you wanted i mean
you wouldn't make anything but you know
i mean that's that's like i love hearing
republicans say there's a labor shortage
i'm like no there's not there's a labor
demand like that's the pro that that's
the problem with with businesses it's
businesses problem it's not the labor's
problem that your demand for labor is
not is not the labor's problem your
demand for prop
your demand for labor is your problem as
a business you have to solve that
problem and when you live in a
capitalist system the way you solve
those problems like that is you pay more
money
like that is how you solve that problem
it was funny i seen a story the other
day and i forget the company but it was
a big restaurant chain and it was down i
think it's in the southeast part of the
country and i think it's like a burger
chain and and they were like stressed
out about their labor shortage and it
this whole article you know the media is
so stupid to play into this this
narrative but they they talked about how
this company was struggling with the
labor shortage and all this and like
they finally discovered how they could
just fix their labor shortage was to
give people more benefits and pay them a
higher wage i'm like oh my god
are you are you [ __ ] kidding me
like like this whole story is about how
they solved their labor shortage like
they did not solve their labor shortage
they just fulfilled the demand of labor
by paying more to get it so that they
could serve their customers like what
the [ __ ] are how can you people be so
out of sorts that you do not understand
simple capitalism things and the thing
that gets me the most is most the time
it's just these freedom people that want
to throw their pocket constitution at
you and talk about how this is a
capitalist society and capitalism
capitalism's the best ever and freedom
and all this crap and they have no clue
how free markets work they have no clue
how labor markets work how businesses
work i actually uh gable today i did it
on my twitch stream i did a uh trump
humping butt plugs analogy to kevin
mccarthy while he was on the floor the
house speaking about how economics work
and how supply and demand works and how
profit margins work and i was uh
i called it mcfluffer's
what i got mcfluffer's trump humping
butt plugs or something yeah
yeah it was fantastic again it's this
thing of people outraged about stuff
that they don't know the first
fundamental thing about right you don't
know the first like you don't know the
first thing about this topic you
you are and and again it's like they
don't actually know anything about how
any of this stuff works it's just
anti-liberalism right yeah anything that
anything to own the lips baby anything
to own the lips i got kobe to own the
lips [ __ ] that's right that's right i'm
dying i'm dying in a hospital i i'm
gonna leave the hospital that i'm dying
in because i'm gonna own the libs
because not only is covid wrong but a
hospital and getting treatment here is
wrong and i'm just going to own them all
the way to the grave there's an old key
and peel skit that i actually think
would would actually work in real life
like not joking and it's it was when
obama was president and they have this
skit where
in order to get all the things done that
he wants to get done he just goes into
this like this like cabinet meeting with
like a bunch of uh stickler republicans
that aren't letting things pass and he
just proposes bills that are the
opposite of what he wants and they just
keep saying no we're going to do the
opposite of that and like they just like
and he's just proposing all these bills
that are just the opposite of like what
he actually wants and he'll be like well
i i feel like we need uh like um
more freedom for guns like we need more
like easy we need to make access to guns
easier and they're like no
like they're like they they start
getting what he's doing but they can't
help but say no right no
do you really do you really think that i
think that's a possibility like
genuinely the white house could come out
and troll these [ __ ] to get what they
wanted it's so pathetic that that
actually might be a reality but that is
possible to write legislation that is
like the opposite of what they
might have these guys take like a red
pen to it and be like no it should be
this instead and it's like
great oh i guess we have to compromise
with you
[Music]